North Korea says these are the pictures
of its latest missile tests on Sunday
South Korea and Japan say the weapons
launched were short-trained ballistic
missiles
on Saturday Pyongyang tested what he
described as a rocket launcher system
that can deliver tactical nuclear
weapons
Kim yo Jong the sister of North Korea's
leader says whether to use the Pacific
Ocean as its shooting range depends on
the United States Japan has demanded an
emergency U.N security Council meeting
to discuss the issue
since last year North Korea has
repeatedly launched missiles in quick
succession significantly increasing
tensions North Korea's series of actions
threatens the peace and security of
Japan the region and the International
Community and are absolutely
unacceptable
U.S and South Korean war planes carried
out a highly visible response to
Saturday's launch South Korea's defense
Ministry said that drills headed by
nuclear-capable American B-1 bombers a
firmed the United States commitment to
the extended deterrence of its nuclear
weapons
the U.S and Japan held a similar
separate exercise of the Waters of
Japan's West Coast North Korea I think
basically wants to deter the US and
South Korea from doing military drills
the US and South Korea would like to
deter North Korea from conducting
additional missile tests but that's not
really what deterrence does it's really
just about trying to prevent the others
raising the cost to the other side of
potential conflict or War
years of diplomacy sanctions and
international censure have done little
to slow North Korea's missile program
Mohamed van al-jazeera